a couple of meters from sort of
breaching and after such a sudden storm
that's quite an oddity despite the wet
weather of recent days the river Chew in
Somerset is well below its normal level
a dry winter has meant the river has yet
to recover from last Summer's drought
and the warm weather will soon return
ecologists fear for the impact on
Wildlife we've got less fish in the
river less abundance of particular
species course and migratory fish so for
me it's going to be that impact the The
Aquatic Wildlife the invertebrates as
well at the base of ecology and the food
chain they are going to be impacted by
low flows new data for February shows
that many rivers in England Wales and
Northern Ireland were at exceptionally
low levels for the end of the winter for
we're at the lowest on record
underground aquifers were also below
normal in many areas for the time of
year with one in South Wales at its
lowest in almost three decades and many
reservoirs still aren't topped up
coliford in Cornwall isn't even half
full
February was the dryer since 1993 and
across the whole winter some parts of
the country had less than 70 percent of
the normal rainfall it means the soil
the rivers the underground aquifers have
much less water going into the summer
the southwest and the east of England
are still officially in drought but
across much of the country the soil is
significantly drier than normal
scientists say the lack of rain at this
time of year really matters it's a dry
Winters that really have
the greater impact on water resources
than the dry Summers really the dry
summers are when we when we feel the
impacts ourselves in restrictions on on
supplies and so forth but it's the dry
Winters where those resources don't get
replenished which then knock on and
cause those problems into the summer and
into the autumn
millions of people endured a hose pipe
ban last year we could be spared another
drought by a monsoon spring but there is
no significant rain in the long range
forecast Thomas More Sky News in
Somerset